Yeah. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, aus dem Keller raus, meinen Chor und hat was Schönes eingespielt. Toll, finde ich gut. Ja, auch so bei Herr der Ringe, David Howard Shaw hat eben die Musik gemacht, ne? Du weißt es besser. Der hat ja auch wahrscheinlich bei Sauron erstmal so eine andere Melodie nehmen wollen, irgendwie ohne Chor, weil das ist ja Klischee. Aber im Endeffekt hat er sich dann doch dafür entschieden, oder Percy Jackson, Peter Jackson hat gesagt, nee, du musst schon den Chor nehmen, weil es angemessen ist.
Vorher hat er wahrscheinlich auch so eine Melodie für Sauron, und dann hat Peter Jackson gesagt, nein, Chor, wäre mein Chor gebührt, und dann halt so Orphortuna-mäßig hat er dann ja auch den Chor. Ursprünglich sollten ja die Hobbits den Korps kriegen und Sauron diese lustige Fidel und dann muss er bei Perseverance nochmal einschreiten und sagen, Stopp, errent an der Stelle, können wir das nochmal, können wir nochmal einen Swap-a-Roo machen? Ja, wir machen einen kleinen Swap-a-Roo näher rum. Nein, das war ja auch das Genial, die Bonus-Sachen auf der DVD sind eh genial, wie sie dann alles nochmal geswitcht haben und ja auch ursprünglich
die Hobbits die Hörner haben sollten und
rufen und diesen Dreizack.
Eigentlich sollte ja Saruman barfüssig sein, die ganze
Zeit mit so Shorts, mit so kurzen
Cargo-Pants eigentlich.
Und die Hobbits sollten wirklich festes
Schuhwerk haben, aber dann hat auch Perseverance
gemeint, nee, lass uns hier nochmal
einen kurzen Stopp-Punkt machen,
alle Dreharbeiten anhalten und das einfach nochmal aus. Tauscht einfach mal die Schuhe aus, wechsel das einfach aus. Wir machen Swap-a-Roo. Kurze Frage, gibt es einen Bösewicht in der Filmgeschichte, der Schorst trägt? Ich glaube nicht. Mark Zuckerberg vielleicht, wenn man ihn als Bösewicht bezeichnen möchte. Na, das, darüber streiten die Geister. Aber ich weiß es nicht, das nee, ich glaube nicht, ich glaube, das schließt sich wirklich aus. Das war meine Herausforderung. Ich glaube, das schließt sich aus. Waden. Weil Waden haben denkbar entwaffnende Fähigkeit. Das ist halt irgendwie, wenn du deine Waden zeigst, dann kannst du niemandem was Böses tun. Satan hat er nicht auch nur so, also normalerweise wird Satan ja mit so Ziegenbeinen dargestellt. Genau, Satan ist untenrum halt ein Ziegenbock. Ja, aber der hat auch oft nur Fell bis zum Knie, das heißt, eigentlich trägt Satan Shorts, im Grunde. Ja, aber es ist ein Fell, aber dann hat er diese Hufen, die machen es glaube ich wieder, ich glaube das Prinzip Wade ist einfach das entwaffnende Element. Ja, das stimmt schon, es ist unangenehm, aber ganz kurz, Howard Shaw, falls du zuhörst, ich hätte Bock auf einen Prank. Ich hätte Bock auf einen coolen Prank. Wir sind ja mittlerweile bekannt, die Pranks der deutschen Podcast-Szene. Und ich hätte Bock auf einen Prank, irgendwie der nächste Herr der Ringe, die Serie oder so und dann der große Tag, Percy steht in der Tonkabine und sagt, was hast du vorbereitet? Das erste Mal spielt er vor und dann spielt er halt wirklich so Blockflöte,, einfach so eine Melodie, die es schon gibt, einem kompletten Orchester und Percy so, ja, ich sehe, wo du hin willst. dann dann dann dann dann dann dann dann dann dann dann dann dann für die krieührungkei kommen. Und dann Ja, super. Ja, hat was. Ich glaube, ich verstehe, wo du hin willst. Können wir sicherheitshalber noch mal gucken, ob es nicht Crazy Frog ist? Ich glaube, das muss bei allen, ich glaube, das ist eigentlich die Hauptaufgabe von Musikproduzenten, ist zu checken. Axel F ausschließen. Ist es nicht Axel F? Auf der ersten Seite von wie komponiere ich ein Musikstück, erst mal immer fragen, ist es Axel F? Ist es Axel F? Und dann, wie kann man sich es vorstellen, so ein Flussdiagramm. Oben ist ist es Axel F? Und dann, wenn du Nein bist, dann steht eine andere Frage. Ist es Oops, I did it again? Und dann Nein, okay, good to go. Und dann so drei Dollarrei Dollarzeichen und dann so ein Swickersmiley. Here we go. Ja, nee, aber finde ich eine gute Idee. Unser Prank von letzter Woche kam ja nicht so gut an. Wir hatten vorgeschlagen, eine Marslandung zu pranken und die Kandidaten zu pranken. Stellt sich raus, es gab diese Sendung schon, wo Leute auf eine Marsmission geschickt wurden, aber nicht als Prank. Es gab mal die Idee von irgendwelchen kruden Niederländern, die meinten, sie sammeln viel Geld und wollen 2023 jemanden auf den Mars schießen. Und haben dann das Geld verschludert und es nicht mehr gefunden. Und dann hat sich das auch aufgelöst. Bitte was? Ich habe die Sendung jetzt nicht verstanden. Die haben leider ... Was ist die Sendung? Die Sendung ist Wir fliegen zum Mars. Mars, Mars, wir fliegen zum Mars. Ja, Mars ist nur einmal im Jahr. Genau, das war so die Grundidee. Diese kruden Holländer, ne? Und dann haben die krudesten der Holländer sich zusammengerafft und haben gesagt, ja, wir casten jetzt Leute, Lotto, Lotterieverfahren, Kreuzworträtsel, alles mögliche, um da zehn Leute zu finden, die gesagt haben, oh, stimmt, ich habe das Allerwichtigste vergessen. Ja, ich merke das nämlich, ohne zu wissen, dass was fehlt, merke ich, dass was fehlt. Also, was fehlt ist, Achtung, noch mal kurz einfügen, es war eine One-Way-Mission. Die sollten zum Mars, aber nicht zurück. Also die hatten eine riesige Rakete, die die einfach willkürlich auf dem Mars verteilt. Was ist Fiktion an der Geschichte? Nichts, nichts ist Fiktion, nichts. Die wollten die Holländer das Raumfahrerland-Holland. Die haben eine grosse Flasche mit Druckluft gefüllt und wollten so mit so ... Die haben Mentos und Cola in rauen Mengen. Die kruden Holländer haben Mentos. Mentos, Backpulver und Cola Light zusammengepackpackt in einer großen Flasche. Und die Mythbusters, die das Ganze beauftrittsichtigt haben als leitende Forscher. Und dann so wie so ein Bierbike saßen dann fünf Leute oben auf dieser Flasche drauf. Dumbo Schreiner saß auf der Flasche drauf und die Mythbusters haben gesagt, hä? Genau, zusammen mit den vier Kilometer und die sollten einmal so zum Mars fliegen, aber dann nicht zurück, Das war die Idee. So, jetzt mal kurz Spaß beiseite. Aber ich meine den ganzen Spaß kurz beiseite, okay? Nehmen wir noch eine Spasmütze auf. Ne, ich habe drei Sekunden auf den Spassknopf gedrückt, ist aus. Okay, ist aus. Also, kurz spaßfreie Zone. Was davon ist jetzt echt? Die haben eine, das Raumfahrerland Holland hat ja wohl jetzt nicht eine Rakete gehabt. Ja, lass es Dänemark sein, lass es Dänemark sein. Ach so. Die haben, also generell in der Show ging es darum, wer hat Bock zum Mars zu fliegen, ganz viele Hände gehen hoch, aber ihr kommt nicht mehr zurück. Die meisten Hände gehen runter, aber nicht alle. Und da setzt diese Sendung an. Genau, und da geht es los, wer hat hier noch die Flosse in der Luft und dann holt man die raus und sagt, warum willst du alleine auf dem Mars sterben? Was davon ist die Sendung? Ist das das Casting und dann geht die Sendung los? Das ist alles vor der Sendung. Ja, okay, gut. Gut, dass wir da anfangen. Bei dem Pitch. Was ist in der Sendung? Wir sind ungefähr jetzt T-3 Wochen. So, wir gehen auf Sendung, was passiert? Ja, okay, wir gehen auf Sendung, wir sehen ein Wrack, ein brennendes, schmorendes Wrack.
Davor die Reporterin, die sagt, hier ist die Rakete abgestürzt. Vielleicht hätten wir die Sendung lieber ein bisschen früher beginnen lassen sollen. Jetzt ist abgestürzt, alle kaputt. Ich frage noch, ist der Spaßknopf aus? Du hast gesagt, ja. Er blinkt, er braucht immer, um runterzufahren, er blinkt noch. Lässt nicht zweifeln, ob dein Spassknopf nicht vielleicht klemmt und seit ein paar Jahren einfach angestecken geblieben ist. Kann man mit dir, ich will an dir rütteln und sagen, wo ist der echte Florentin? Gut, okay, also drei Zentimeter Schicht Ironie und Zynismus weggespült, darunter kommt eine herrliche Persönlichkeit zum Vorstein. Aber in Grafit. In so einem Grafit-Kern. Ja, so schimmernd glänzend. Also die haben gesagt, wir machen eine Sendung und wir haben Geld und wir brauchen Leute, die wollen zum Mars aber nicht zurück. Die wollen dahin aber nicht zurück. Ja. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, wer macht das? Wer will das machen? Stellt sich raus, ziemlich viele Leute haben sich da beworben, die gesagt haben, Erde ist nicht meins, habe mich hier noch nie wohlgefühlt. Ist es meistens zu warm oder zu kalt. Genau, ein ewiges Hin und Her zwischen zu warm und zu kalt. Winter ist zu kalt, Sommer ist zu warm, man kennt es. Manchmal so im März hat man so gute 20 Minuten, wo es genau richtig ist. Ja, für zwei Tage hat man dann vielleicht mal Wetter, wo man sagt, das ist mein Wetter. Aber danach ist es schon wieder zu warm. Wisst ihr was, Mars. Ja. Wo es nachts, dann wenigstens, wenn extreme Wetter, dann richtig extrem. Dann so richtig minus 80 Grad Celsius. Ich liebe autonomes Fahren. Mars, 100 Prozent autonomes Fahren. Das ist ein Planet, der an die Zukunft denkt. Und dann haben sich viele Leute beworben und dann kann man natürlich mit denen tolle Interviews führen. Warum haben sie niemanden hier auf der Erde, der sie vermissen wird, nein. Die Show ist die Interviews. Nein, nein, wie gesagt, denkt man nicht an die Show gerade, denkt man nicht an die Show. Die Show hat noch nicht angefangen. Also, du bist so ungeduldig immer, immer der Pitch, nach einer Stunde stellst du schon Nachfragen beim Pitch und willst wissen, wann das Geld reinklimpert. Du musst vorher, ich bin viel zu ungeduldig.
Ich fange nach einer Woche an, Fragen zu stellen,
wo ich dann auch sagen muss, nee, du bist erst mal dran am Erzählen. Sorry.
So, und das Problem an der,
die Showidee ist gut, die ist richtig gut.
Das Problem ist, du musst natürlich
irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass die Leute tatsächlich auf
Mars kommen. Mars 2023
sollte die Show stattfinden,
2023 Jahre. Das ist wie viel, wenn man Jeff Bezos Vermögen nimmt, wie viel ist das im Vergleich zu, weil das habe ich jetzt mittlerweile gut mir verbildlicht. Ja, ja. 2023 kann ich mir noch nicht vorstellen. Genau, also wenn Cleopatra damals so viel gehabt hätte, wie Jeff Bezos heute hat, in Eseln und alle alle Esel aufgestapelt hätte. Aber so als Wheelie. Alle Esel machen Wheelie und stellen sich aufeinander. Und der Abstand, der dann noch von dem höchsten Esel zum Mars ist, so viel Geld kostet es, einmal zum Mars zu fliegen. Und die haben gesagt, 2023, das ist ja noch lange hin. Bis dahin können wir bestimmt Geld sammeln. Und konnten sie nicht, hatten kein Geld, konnten sich die Rakete nicht leisten und haben den Laden zugemacht. Die haben den Laden zugemacht. Was wäre denn die Show jetzt gewesen? Naja, und dann hast du 20 Leute, die in einem Wartezimmer sitzen und sagen, wie, wir kommen jetzt noch nicht zum Mars, ich habe allen gesagt, lasst mich in Ruhe, ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf euch, ich fliege zum Mars. Ich habe dich betrogen, Schatz, by the way. Ich habe gekündigt mit den Worten, fickt euch, ich fliege zum Mars. Fickt euch, ich bin auf dem Mars. Wie soll ich da nächste Woche wieder zurückkommen und sagen, sorry, sorry, wir machen einfach weiter, als wäre nichts passiert. Ich, ich fliege nirgendwo hin, ich bleibe hier. Ich fliege nicht mal nach Holland. Ich bin schon, vielleicht bin ich in der Endemark, ich weiß es nicht genau. Aber das war so ein bisschen die Grundidee. So, jetzt, worauf ich hinaus wollte, ist, jemand hatte schon dieselbe Idee wie wir, nur ohne Prank. Ja, aber das ist ja doof. Was bildet sich denn Holland oder Dänemark ein, zum Mars fliegen zu können? Wobei, die haben eigentlich ohne es zu wollen Prankshows gemacht. Die hatten am Ende einfach nur kein Geld mehr. Wir wollten ja von Anfang an nie diese Rakete bauen. Es ist wie eine Prankshow, in der sie vergessen haben, die Kameras anzumachen. Genau. Ja, letztlich.
Ist es nicht das ganze Leben eine Prankshow, bei der keine Kamera läuft? Ist nicht das Leben eine Show, bei der keine Kamera läuft? Ich beantworte eine andere Frage. Und zwar wollte ich dich schon fragen. Gibt es einen Film, wo sich drei Leute gleichzeitig küssen? Ich glaube noch nicht. Und da setzen wir an. Also, ich sehe drei Lippenpaare vor mir, die awkward versuchen, in einer Dreieckssituation zusammenzukommen. Also in einer Situation, du erzählst das klassische, da kennst du ja mich schon an, ein Liebesdreieck. Du hast ein klassisches Liebesdreieck, A liebt B, B liebt C, C liebt A und dann wilde Zerwürfnisse. B hatte noch was mit A. Genau. A sagt, aber nee, H war immer schon mein Traummann. Genau, und dann sagt B, Moment mal, ich dachte, du wärst C. Nein, ich bin D. Aber ich war mal B. Ach so. Ich war mal B, aber ich bin dann zu D geworden, weil D ist, ich bin geboren, ich wusste immer schon, dass ich D bin. Ja, und dann kommt F und verkuppelt A mit D, obwohl D ja eigentlich in C verliebt ist. Und dann sagt C, jetzt merke ich's, aber dann ist D schon mit A und so weiter. Ihr kennt die Geschichtshut. Also Liebesdreieck und Liebeshexagon. Genau, Liebesparallelogramm und am Ende kommen alle zusammen. Das Liebes-Tetraeder kennt jeder, klassisches Element der Heldenreise. Spätestens wenn es dreidimensional wird, wird es anspruchsvoll. Dann wird es wirklich verrückt. Das Liebes-Ikosaeder. Liebe kennt keine Grenzen. Das wäre mal so als Pitch. Ja, oder Liebe, was, was, wie, okay, Achtung. Aber das war alles vor dem Film. Namen, das war alles vor dem Film. Der Film ich überlege gerade, Namen für eine mathematische Rom-Com, sowas wie Liebe zieht keine Wurzel oder so, oder Liebe hoch drei. Liebe hoch drei ist ein gutes Dreieck. Ja, die Wurzel aus einer Unbekannten ziehen, finde ich heutzutage. Ja, oder A Quadrat plus B Quadrat ist gleich Liebe, sowas in der Richtung. Auf jeden Fall, liebes Dreieck, Zerwürfnisse hin und her, die trennen sich wieder, merken dann, dass ihr altes Leben ihnen keinen Spaß macht, denken nur noch aneinander und so weiter und so weiter. Und dann hebt ein Flugzeug ab und die sagen nein und treffen sich alle am Flughafen zu dritt und gestehen sich ihre Liebe, aber sie sind zu dritt. Und das ist das Besondere an dem Film, dass du nicht am Ende ein zweier Paar hast, sondern du hast ein dreier Paar und sagst, wir lieben uns alle gleich und alles ist super und dann kommt der große Kuss und drei Menschen küssen sich gleichzeitig, was noch nie auf die Leinwand gebannt wurde. Doch. Und wir sehen es von oben, aber wir sehen es aus der Vogelperspektive, wie die drei Köpfe aufeinander zugehen. Ja, und dann bildet sich, dann wird drüber gemalt so ein Dreieck. So über die Köpfe. Genau, wie bei Kill Bill. Wie bei Kill Bill wird dann auch veranschaulicht, dass es jetzt gerade ein liebes Dreieck ist. Verstehen Sie? Und Percy Jackson guckt in die Kamera und sagt, verstehen Sie? Verstehen Sie es jetzt? Jetzt macht der Titel den Abspann. Moment, du hast was gefunden? Und zwar kenne ich nämlich Itumama Tambien von Alfonso Cuaron.
Einen Film, den er gemacht hat, bevor er ...
Harry Potter und die Gefangenen von Oscar Mayer machte,
bevor er Gravity gemacht hat, Roma, die ganzen tollen Filme,
für die Alfonso Cuaron lieben und schätzen.
Davor hat er einen Film gemacht, der hieß Itumama Tambien,
über zwei Jungen und eine Frau.
Und sie verlieben sich zu dritt und am Ende
küssen sie sich zu dritt.
Wie sieht das aus? Hast du die Szene da?
Habe ich jetzt nicht parat. Warum nicht?
Hast du ein GIF? Ich habe ein GIF.
Schau mal, weil das würde mich interessieren, weil
wie küsst... Nein, das ist einfach ein Dreier.
Liebeszene zu dritt, aber alle küssen sich.
Aber nicht gleichzeitig. Das ist ja wahrscheinlich, was darauf hinausgeht. Ja, genau, ich will, dass sie sich gleichzeitig küssen. Dass alle drei Lippenpaare sich gleichzeitig berühren. Das hat man noch nie gesehen im Fernsehen, im Kino. Hast du das manchmal, dass Pornosuchen zu spezifisch sind? Weil wenn das jetzt dein Kink, dein Fetisch ist, drei Lippenpaare berühren sich, vergesst die Zahl drei, maximal viele Lippenpaare berühren sich gleichzeitig. Zwei plus, mehr als zwei. Ja, und dann sucht man das und dann gibt es da kein Porno zu. Ja, es gab mal einen und der ist nicht mehr online, das ist das Allerschlimmste, das ist das Allerschlimmste. Oh mein Gott, du hattest das Lesenzeichen noch. Und du bist drauf und es existiert nicht. Genau, und du denkst dir, Moment mal Verlauf. Ich war im Inkognito-Fenster. Mein verbündeter Inkognito-Fenster fällt mir in den Rücken. Was war die längste, guck mal jetzt hier, Hände auf den Tisch. Okay. Was ist die längste Zeit, die du mal gebraucht hast, um einen Porn, den du magst, wiederzufinden? Boah, wiederzufinden, das kann lange dauern. Weil das hat man manchmal, das kann mir niemand erzählen. Bestimmt eine Stunde, oder? Bestimmt, oder? Ja, ja. Auch sämtliche Angeregtheit verschwunden. Nee, es ist ja nur noch ein, man muss es einfach tun, es wird zur heiligen Pflicht. Es wird zur Obsession. Ja, du we auch nicht, was genau im Titel der Titelgeber als relevant empfunden hat. Weil es sind ja teilweise willkültig, manchmal wird die Haarfarbe erwähnt, manchmal wird das Alter erwähnt, manchmal wird der Ort erwähnt. Und manchmal halt nicht, und du weißt nicht, welche Art von Texten es ist. Und auf allen Seiten heißt dieser Porno ja anders. Es ist grauenhaft manchmal. Das ist wirklich grauenhaft. Manchmal hat man sich auch eine Linksammlung angelegt, die führt dann aber ins Nichts. Du weißt, es ist weg. Dann weißt du nicht, ist es besser oder schlimmer. Du weißt, dass du es auf der Seite nicht mehr finden wirst, sollst du aber jetzt noch in den Dschungel gehen. Du hast eine kleine Insel. Jeder hat seine Insel gefunden. Auf der kennt man auch die lokalen Einwohner. alles ist cool, du weißt, da kriegst du deine Milch. Da kriegst du, was du willst. Du weißt, was du und du weißt, was du begann. Genau, du weißt, der Geldautomat ist und dir ist da noch nichts Schlechtes passiert. Und dann ist die Frage, jetzt gibt es aber diese eine Kokosnuss nicht mehr, die du so gerne isst. Und jetzt ist die Frage, lässt du es jetzt einfach dabei bleiben und holst dir eine Papaya oder steigst du in das Boot und fährst knatternd zu einer anderen Insel? Ja, so. Und da ist aber dunkel, da guckst du dich immer um. Stockdunkel. Hinter jeder Ecke guckst du dich um und denkst, oh Gott, wo bin ich denn jetzt hier gelandet? Und du landest bei Inseln, wo du Angst hast, dich zu infizieren. Genau. Du landest auf dem Weg zu dieser neuen Insel, auf kleinen Inseln, auf die du nicht gehen solltest, weil sonst holst du dir was Schlimmes, eine schlimme Krankheit, eine schlimme Erkältung holst du dir da. Das darfst du nicht. Nee, das darfst du gar keinen Fall. Es sei denn, du bist mit deinem Boot MS McIntosh unterwegs, dann hast du wahrscheinlich, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du dich damit ansteckst, ist geringer. Wir haben ja schon mal über Pornos geredet und da haben wir tatsächlich, hat uns einer geschrieben, der meinte, er hätte mal eine Pornoseite geführt und um ganz ehrlich zu sein, da würde ich gerne mal ein Interview machen, weil also zum Beispiel auf YouTube, da checkt man ja mal mittlerweile ungefähr, wie das Geschäftsmodell funktioniert. Da läuft Werbung, davon kriegt ein gewisser Teil, kriegen die YouTuber, die machen auch Product Placement, da kriegt dann YouTube nichts davon, nur die YouTuber und YouTuber will das möglichst für Leute Werbung sein und du denkst dir, okay, da fließt Geld in einer sinnvollen Art und Weise. Das kann ich nachvollziehen. Was ich überhaupt nicht verstehe, ist, wie funktionieren Pornoseiten? Es gibt Premium-Mitgliedschaften. Das verstehe ich. Aber dann hast du oft auch Werbung vor einem Porno für andere Pornoseiten und denkst, das geht ja erstmal überhaupt nicht. Nö, die allerbeste Werbung. Also generell, wer wirbt davor? Das sind auch nie coole, seriöse Firmen. Ne. Und eine Sprecherin gibt es offensichtlich nur oder einen Sprecher, sind immer gleich gesprochen, wie dem auch sei. Mittlerweile auch oft Computer stimmen, weil sie nicht mal Sprecher finden. Aber die beste Werbung ist, es war kurzem erst gelauncht und die ging so sinngemäß, warum Pornos gucken, wenn man auch selber in einem sein kann? Ja, ich glaube, die habe ich auch schon mal gesehen. Warum Pornos konsumieren, wenn du selber in einem vorkommen kannst? Und ich so, na ja. Weil du vielleicht massiv meinen Körper überschätzt, gute Frau, sorry. Das macht gar keinen Sinn. Das ist aber auch so, wie soll ein gutes
Restaurant gehen, weil du auch
selber deinen Scheiß schlechter nachkochen
kannst. Das ist nicht
vergleichbar.
Das ist die schlechteste Werbung in der ganzen Welt.
Das Geile ist ja, dass ja auch die Werbetexter
schlechter sind. Alles ist Schade.
Es ist wie eine Paralleldimension, wo alle
einfach irgendwie, einfach
um drei Uhr nachmittags aufhören zu arbeiten, wo alles so ein bisschen liegen bleibt. Aber auch so dieses ganze Copyright-Ding. Manchmal werden Pornos entfernt, weil es Copyright-Issues gibt. Aber von wem, an wem, warum gibt es manche Filme auf allen Seiten, manche nur auf einem? Also für mich ergibt es keinen Sinn, was da passiert. Und jetzt wurden sehr viele Videos gelöscht. Es werden immer mal wieder alle gelösöscht. Es gibt so wie so Purges. Ja. So The Purge. Und es war, glaube ich, vor ein paar, lass mich sagen, Monat, vor einem Monat war ungefähr The Purge. Genau, was genau ist da passiert? Das würde mich mal interessieren, weil es gibt ja Insider in der Branche, die das genau checken. Aber ich fühle mich dann mal ein bisschen schuldig, weil ich dachte, was ist das jetzt für, warum wurde der gelöscht? Ja. Was habe ich denn da geguckt? Dann gibt es manchmal, die haben keinen Ton, wo ich mir denke, ist das jetzt für Copyright, dass das nicht gefunden wird oder was? Ganz merkwürdig. Genau, was für Rechte gibt es in diesem rechtelosen System? Es ist doch so ein bisschen Wilder Westen, habe ich das Gefühl. Ist es Wilder Westen oder ist es, weil das ist ja nicht das Dark Web oder so, das ist ja genau dasselbe. Ist es schlimmer. Weiß ich nicht. Das ist ja das Normale, das kannst du ja alles
suchen. Also es ist ja, warum ist es denn der Wilde
Westen? Was ist denn, also natürlich
jetzt mal von der Schlüpfrigkeits
Dimension ist es natürlich der
Wilde Westen, aber rein rechtlich
und technisch ja nicht. Warum ist das
anders? Ich glaube, Pornhub ist gar nicht der
Wilde Westen. Ich glaube, Pornhub ist ein Unternehmen,
was ganz normal,
wenn nicht sogar Börsen notiert ist,
keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall irgendwo
einen Firmensitz hat und glaube ich
Vielen Dank. Ich glaube, Pornhub ist ein Unternehmen, was ganz normal, wenn nicht sogar Börsen notiert ist, keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall irgendwo einen Firmensitz hat und, glaube ich, legal funktioniert. Das Problem an diesem Unternehmen ist aber, und da weiß ich nicht genau, wie man das nachweisen kann, aber anders als YouTube kriegen die es ja nicht in den Griff, genau zu kontrollieren und zu kuratieren, was da hochgeladen wird die ganze Zeit. Ja. Und das ist ja das Riesenproblem. Aber ich glaube, es hat schon den Anspruch, ein Unternehmen zu sein, ein legit Unternehmen zu sein. Ja, die haben ja dann auch so Accounts von so Leuten, die das machen, die haben dann den eigenen Account mit Premium und so gedönst. Das kann ich mir schon vorstellen, wie das funktioniert. Aber ich will eigentlich den, also falls ihr arbeitet für eine richtig schmierige, so eine richtig shady Website, die so richtig hard shady ist. Wo zwischendurch so Pop-Up-Werbung kommt und so, wo man denkt, ach. Wo so ganz merkwürdige Videos ... Aber auch diese Gemeinen, manche, die immer so kurz aufblitzen, dreimal. Die dich beleidigen. Die dich beleidigen oder auch wechseln, dass wenn du auf X klicken willst, dann ändern die sich noch so schnell, dass du dann draufklickst. Die dir so dein Passwort anzeigen und so, okay, wir haben dich in der Hand und so. Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, wir haben dich gefilmt oder so. Also ganz, also falls ihr so eine Mal, falls ihr dadurch euer Geld verdient, no shame, keine Angst, bei uns seid ihr sicher. Ihr könnt anonym bei uns ein Interview führen. Genau, anonym mit verzerrter Stimme. Ihr dürft anonym mit uns ein Interview führen. Unsere Stimmen sind verzerrt, eure Stimme ist verzerrt, wir verzerren alles. Wir verzerren alles. Wir legen coolen Hip-Hop-Beat drunter, mir egal, was es braucht. Was es braucht, ihr kriegt Nüsschen, ihr kriegt Rosinen, was ihr möchtet. Aber ihr kriegt keine Plattform. Doch, na, ein bisschen. Bisschen Plattform. Ihr dürft den Namen der Website nicht nennen. Ja, das meine ich. Aber da, ach so. Ihr kriegt keine Plattform. Ihr Ihr kriegt eine Schüssel Plattformen, aber mehr nicht.
Ja, ihr dürft so ein paar Plattformen snacken. Also da meldet euch auf jeden Fall, das würde uns auf jeden Fall interessieren, würde mich interessieren, weil es gibt so Ecken des Internets, die sind so halb erschlossen irgendwie, das ist so der Visum im tiefen Meer. Glaubst du, man wird, wie man damals dachte, wie es damals wichtig war, angeblich Amerika zu finden, so ist es auch so ein bisschen, wenn man so eine Seite jetzt im Internet findet, also bald vielleicht oder so eine Ecke im Internet findet, es wird ja irgendwann mal so eine Entdeckung geben. Du meinst, es gibt noch eine ganze Website, die noch nie jemand entdeckt hat, oder was? Ich glaube, es gibt mehr als eine ganze Website. Ich glaube, es gibt eine ganze Ecke Webseiten, die noch siten. So eine Endung, so eine Domain-Endung. Die noch nicht erschlossen wurden. Punkt Secret oder so. Und dann geht man da drauf und denkt sich, was ist denn hier gerade bitte los? Ja. Kann das sein, kann das nicht sein? Ich glaube, es kann sein. Ist es wie so ein Land erschließen? Nee. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich glaube, wenn da jemand noch mal irgendwie die ganze Liste an Webseiten durchgeht, findet man da ganz unten noch was. Könnte auch ein guter Film sein, so eine geheime Webseite, die noch nie jemand gefunden hat. The Website. The Website. Und du siehst einen jungen Hund. Okay. Der? Also der Film geht los aus der Perspektive des Hundes. Und denkst dir jetzt mal, what? Ich dachte, das ist so ein Informatikerfilm. Falsch, Perspektive eines Hundes und du siehst die Welt durch die Augen. Heißt der Hund Website? Nein, der Hund heisst Bolo und du siehst die Welt durch die Augen eines Hundes. Wird gerufen, alles ist grau, alles ist fucking grau, also wirklich unanschaubar grau. Und du siehst aber den Ball. Aber sehr gut hörbar. Also man hört erstaunlich gut. Dolby Surround auf Max einfach. Also ganz hoch gedreht. Genau, und der läuft durch die Gegend und du hältst den Ball hinterher und du fängst an zu denken wie ein Hund. Und plötzlich sagt er, hey, komm her, ich will dir was zeigen. und der Junge zeigt dir eine Website, weil der Junge ist noch sehr jung, der ist sieben. Und der redet die ganze Zeit mit dir, aber du verstehst nicht, was er sagt, aber als Zuschauer verstehst du schon, was er sagt. Also der sagt zwar, aber da du selber ein Mensch bist, kannst du schon verstehen, worauf er hinaus will. Und der Junge hat eine Website programmiert. Genau, und dann zeigt er die dem Vater, aber der Vater sagt, ach dein Website-Kram, das interessiert mich nicht. Du bist Vater. Warum bist du nicht genau wie ich in den Motorrad-Club gegangen? Sehr zeitgemäß auch, finde ich gut. Du bist nicht mein Sohn, mit diesem Computerquatsch. Zack, Tür zu. Zack, Musicalnummer. Tür zu. Und du als Hund gehst natürlich zu dem Kind und willst ihn trösten und schlabberst die Tränen von seinem Gesicht. Ja. Und dann sagt er, ich erkläre dir jetzt meine Website, die ich programmiert habe, auf die ich stolz bin, die niemand sonst wertschätzt. Und er zeigte die Website. Und das ist zwar, du willst ihm natürlich Mut machen, aber die ist auch saulangweig, die Website. Als Zuschauer denkt man auch die ganze Zeit, ja, mehr Website, weniger Hund, oder? Ist das denn das Stilmittel? Also jetzt frage ich Sie als Regisseur. Also wir sind jetzt ungefähr 30 Minuten im Film im Film. Und die letzten 25 Minuten ... Aber ich bin etwas, sage ich Ihnen ganz ehrlich, froh, dass der Film schon angefangen hat, zu dem Zeitpunkt der Story. Nur so. Wir sind noch im Textcrawl. Oh mein Gott. Und dann denkt man sich als Hund schon, das zieht sich jetzt aber auch echt ein bisschen, und man fängt an ... Als Hund denkt man. Als Hund denkt der Hund, also man als Zuschauer denkt sich das, aber der Hund denkt sich das zehn Minuten später auch so, boah, das wird jetzt echt. Der Junge hingegen immer noch. Der Junge ist hochmotiviert. Hochmotiviert. Er zeigt dir, hier habe ich das HTML und dann CSS, hier habe ich das und das Plug-in hier und dann der Hund denkt sich aber auch schon, uiuiui. Und dann merkt, sieht der Hund plötzlich eine Fliege durch den Raum fliegen. Und die ist plötzlich viel interessanter. Und die Aufmerksamkeit ist voran, die ist viel spannender. Genau, aber der Hund ist jetzt gefangen. Und der Junge aber auch so, ehrlich, eine Fliege? Ja, weil der Hund muss jetzt gucken, er will ja seinen Menschen nicht enttäuschen, aber die Fliege ist halt schon fucking interessant. Und visuell kann man das natürlich auch aufarbeiten. Die Fliege ist ganz bunt, verstrahlt, so bunte Farben und auch die Akustik wird so dargestellt. Und jetzt sehen wir alles aus Sicht der Fliege wenigstens? Nee, nee, nee. Weiterhin. Weiterhin. Die Fliege reibt sich die Fühler und du denkst dir, das ist die beste fucking Fliege. Ist The Website der beste Titel dieses Films? Ne, pass auf, pass auf, es geht ja noch weiter. So, und die Fliege fliegt um den Hund herum und der Hund guckt so die Fliege an und die Fliege landet auf dem Keyboard. Das weiss der Hund aber nicht, weil er nicht weiss, was ein Keyboard ist. Und dann jetzt der Film nähert sich seit dem ersten Punkt langsam, langsam. Und der Junge erzählt und erzählt, der Junge hat es noch nicht gesehen mit der Fliege und der Hund kann es irgendwann nicht mehr tragen, das ist
fucking langweilige Website, ich check das nicht,
haut, kann sich nicht mehr zurückhalten,
haut mit seiner Pranke auf die Fliege,
haut, es kann man auch häufig sehen, wie Hunde
mit ihrer Pranke nach Fliegen klatschen,
haut auf die Tastatur
drauf und ändert den Code
der Website. In
Abspann. Excellent. Und dann ändert die Website in Punkt Secret. Und jetzt machen wir einen harten Cut und wir sehen den Vater auf dem Motorrad, der nach Hause kommt und sagt, tut mir leid, mein Sohn, dass ich da so vorhin zu Gemeins zu dir war, ich bin nochmal umgedreht, ich habe dir hier diesen Eisbecher gekauft. Achso, ich dachte Motorrad, aber okay. Der ist zwar schon geschmolzen, aber du wirst die Geste bestimmt wertschätzen. Ja. Er öffnet die Tür, der Junge ist weg. Der Junge ist weg. Ja, ja, habe ich verstanden. Und wo ist er? Der ist weg, der ist nicht mehr da. Wo ist er. Und der Vater denkt sich, oh nein, jetzt ist der vielleicht weggelaufen, weil ich so gemein zu ihm war. Und da wurde es kurz, ehrlich gesagt, filmisch. Es wurde ganz kurz filmisch, aber jetzt wieder ein wenig Gefühl. Und nee, jetzt kommt eine ganz lange Schwarzblende. Der Film wird immer schwärzer. Und also der ist in irgendeiner Cyberwelt drin und muss sich dann wieder aus dem Code rausarbeiten. Hallo, das ist der spannende und dann am Ende. Hä, wie sind die Gefichte darüber hinweg, dass der Spannende hat? Nein, weil der Hund, der Hund checkt das irgendwann. Der Hund ist mir ein bisschen egal. Der Hund nicht so nahe trägt. Nein, das ist mein Film! Wie will er sich aus der Website... Es ist mein Film! Wie will er sich aus der Website herausholen? Der Hund checkt das irgendwann und wird zu einem Hunde... und genau, er tippt dann den Hunde-Emoji ein und der Junge im Programm liest das und denkt sich Ah, Bolo, da bist du ja, aber hilft nichts. Und ähm... Bolo. Bolo,, und wie schreibt man Bolo? B-O-L-O. Und, ähm, ja, der Junge kommt dann über das ... Denken Sie sich den Film gerade aus, während Sie mit mir sprechen? Nein, der ist halt schon gedreht. Und auf jeden Fall, der Vater lässt was von dem Eis fallen auf den Rechner, der Hund schlägt es ab, kommt aber aus Versehen auf das Diskettenlaufwerk, Auswurfknopf, gedrückt da drauf, die Diskette wird aufgeworfen und der Junge hängt sich da dran und kommt so wieder aus dem Computer raus, ist aber immer noch sehr klein.
Klar, aber das kann man dann auch nicht ändern.
Das kann man nicht ändern.
Das muss reichen als Happy End.
Ende. Gut. So. Ja, nee, finde ich gut. Das war The Website. The Website. Man, es ist echt frustrierend, Ihnen Filme zu pitchen, muss ich auch mal sagen als Feedback. Ich möchte, also naja, Sie kommen hier rein, pitchen Filme, pitchen Formate. Wie viel Zeit denken sie habe ich? Also, weil sie fangen immer vorher an. Man denkt, du kannst viel auch überspringen. Ja, weil du schon so ein paar Jahre herkommst. Jeden Tag haben wir jetzt einen Termin. Ehrlich gesagt. Ja, und ich überlege die zukünftigen zwei Wochen zu canceln. Was haben Sie morgen um 14 Uhr vor? Ja, da steht ein Termin mit Ihnen im Kalender. Na wunderbar. Dann würde ich sagen, bis morgen. Sehen wir uns bis morgen. Fuck yeah. Tschüss. Ja, tschö. Kann man auch nicht mit ihm sagen. Ja, tschö. Ja, tschüssikowski. Ja, tschau tschesku. Ja, ich möchte dir nur mal kurz sagen. Ich bin, ich fühle mich so geehrt und bin so stolz. Und ich freue mich so sehr für dich. Du bist für den Grimme-Preis nominiert. Zusammen mit Colin Gabel für deine Senfshow bei Rocket Beans. Die grosse Senfverkostung. Ich bin so stolz, dich zu kennen. Dankeschön. Und ich hab mich so gefreut, als ich das gesehen hab. Weil der Grimmepreis, muss man ja sagen, der ignoriert den einfachen Spaß, den Jux. Da kommen immer die grossen relevanten Themen. Wir kämpfen ja schon seit Jahrzehnten nun mittlerweile dafür, dass auch einfach Unterhaltung Selbstzweck sein kann, so ein bisschen.
Und ich finde es ganz toll, dass es die Sendverkostung geschafft hat.
Ich bin sehr stolz.
Ja, ich bin heute Morgen aufgeracht, ich habe mit vielm gerechnet,
aber nicht, dass ich für den Adolf-Gribbe-Preis nominiert sein werde. Da habe ich das auf Twitter gesehen, dachte mir,
oh krass, Pen and Paper wirft moralische Konflikte auf,
kann natürlich auch mal den Horizont erweitern,
neue Medien erschließen, irgendwie, klar, Podcast Podcasting jetzt schon auch lange im Game mit dabei. Aber nee, zwei Stunden Senfessen im Fernsehen reicht anscheinend für Herrn Grimme. Herr Grimme hat gesagt, zwei Stunden Senfessen, das finde ich gut, das finde ich super und hat dann gesagt, das ist Grimme preisverdächtig. Anders als alle anderen Sachen, die bei Rocket Beans laufen, die nicht. Genau, es ist das einzige, was nominiert wurde von Rocket Beans und also als Speerspitze. Glücklicherweise fragen Leute in der Regel nicht nach, wofür man einen Grimme-Preis gewonnen hat. Also klar, ich schreibe das dann auf Tinder hier, Florentin, Reiselustig Grimme-Preisträger. Reiselustig Grimme-Preisträger und da fragt in der Regel niemand nach, wofür genau hast du einen Grimme-Preis bekommen. Und wenn, dann kann man immer noch das Match auflösen. Genau, das ist immer der Punkt. Aber ja, ich will jetzt auch noch nicht zu viel versprechen, weil ich bin nur nominiert. Ja, jetzt stell mal dein Licht nicht unter den Scheffel. Nee, aber ... Ich möchte explizit, dass du dein Licht nicht unter den Scheffel stellst. Okay, gut. Kein Scheffel. Kein Scheffel weg. Ich finde das super. Ja, ich schmeisse den gleich weg. Sonne dich mal ein bisschen in den Licht. Ich schmeisse den Scheffel gleich weg, jetzt wo du es sagst. Ich habe den auch seit Monaten nicht mehr verwendet. Nee, den hast du auch. Nee, ich hau den raus. Ich hau den raus. Scheffel zu verschenken, stell den raus auf die Strasse, heute starker Wind. Und wir gucken mal, wer es zuerst kriegt, Mensch oder Natur. Wir gucken einfach, was passiert. Wir schauen einfach, was passiert. Ist die Natur dem Menschen zu nahe gekommen? Nein. Ist der Mensch der Natur zu nahe gekommen? Nein. Hat Mensch und Natur den perfekten Abstand? Ja. Für mich auch. Aber der Mensch versucht, sich die Natur untertan zu machen, zum Beispiel durch Mathematik. Ach so, ich war bei was anderes. Mathematik. Spenden. Ja. Aber jetzt tun sich zwei Dimensionen auf. Ihr könnt jetzt entweder dem einen Podcast folgen oder dem anderen. Das finde ich super. Aber wir laufen gleichzeitig durch. Also ihr habt euch jetzt für die einen entschieden. Euer Gehirn hat sich intuitiv für eine der beiden Möglichkeiten entschieden. Wir wissen selber nicht, welches geworden ist. Okay. Die andere Spur, ehrlich gesagt, sieht besser aus. Aber egal, egal, wir sind jetzt hier. Denn du hast es mit deinem Spenden geschafft, Luchse zu retten. Ich habe Luchse gerettet, ja. Wir haben eine Nachricht mehrere Male bekommen, neben Grimme, vor dem Adolf Grimme-Preis nominiert, haben wir auch ganz viele Nachrichten bekommen, der Luchs ist gerettet. Genau. Dem Luchs geht es wieder gut. Ich habe aus eigenem Antrieb und aus reiner Luchsliebe habe ich für Luchse gespendet.
Nächsten Luchs.
Liebe deinen Luchs, wie dein Nächsten heißt es in der Bibel.
Und da habe ich natürlich auch mal den Geldbeutel grosszügig aufgemacht.
Wie viel hast du gespendet?
Also auf jeden Fall, ich habe, also jetzt kam heute die Nachricht rein von der Tagesschau, Instagram Tagesschau.
Und zwar die Tagesschau, natürlich bekannt für investigativen Journalismus und bricht das Ganze runter auf drei Wörter, nämlich wieder mehr Luchse. Es klingt wie eine Forderung. Es klingt wie eine Forderung, wie so ein Schild, ein Protestschild. Also es ist, das sind die drei Wörter, die uns die journalistische Speerspitze Deutschlands hier an die Hand reicht. Kein Untertitel, nichts. Nichts, gar nichts, sondern drei Wörter, wieder mehr Luchse. Wir wissen weder, ob das ein gutes Zeichen ist, ob das gewollt ist, noch ob das jetzt eine Menge ist, die jetzt reicht. Ist das eine Drohung? Oder ist es so
equivalent für keine Spenden
mehr für Luchse, bitte?
Bitte hört auf, Geld zu spenden.
Es geht weiter in der Unterschrift.
Also im Bildunterschrift. Der Bestand von Luchsen in Deutschland
entwickelt sich positiv.
Ja?
Was übersprichst du da?
Der Naturschutzbund
NABU warnt,
dass trotz des leichten
Sekunde Bestand des Anstiegs
Die Aufmerksamkeit ist ein sehr guter Punkt. Der Naturschutzbund NABU warnt, dass trotz des leichten Bestandesanstiegs die Ausbreitung des Luchses immer noch gefährdet sei. Auch die Umweltstiftung WWF gibt zu bedenken, dass die schlechte Vernetzung von geeigneten Lebensräumen weiterhin ein Problem bleibe. Luchse brauchen zusammenhängende grosse Lebensräume mit viel Wald, Rückzugsorten, ausreichend Beutetieren, wie Rehen zum Leben und auf ihre Jungen aufzuziehen. Als Nachrichtensprecher sollen sie bitte neutral sein. Ich bin neutral. Nein, das müssen Sie jetzt nochmal vorlesen. Neutral. Nein, sie stehen nach wie vor auf der roten Liste der vom Aussterben bedrohten Arten. Also, ja, vielen Dank für die Sprecherprobe. Ehrlich gesagt, also ich habe das Gefühl, dass es ein bisschen, dass Sie eine Meinung, dass Sie ein bisschen vorbehalten sind, was das Thema Luchse angeht. Haben Sie was gegen Luchse? Weil Sie haben es gerade so vorgetragen, als hätten Sie was gegen Luchse. Naja, also ich finde schon, dass es ein bisschen viel verlangt ist,
oder nicht? Also die wollen grosse Wälder,
grosse Rehe, finde ich
einfach nicht gut. Okay, dann haben Sie wohl irgendwas gegen Luchse?
Es wäre trotzdem wichtig, dass Sie diese
Nachrichtenmeldung, dass Sie da
einfach ihre politische Meinung,
warum auch immer sie so geartet
gegen Luchse ausgepegelt ist,
zurückstellen und einfach nur die Meldung.
Ich lese einfach nochmal völlig richtig. Tut mir jetzt leid.
Kein Problem.
Ich habe mich ein bisschen von meinen Emotionen auch mitreissen.
Geil.
Alles klar.
Okay.
Gern nochmal eine neue Chance.
Können Sie vielleicht um es zum Reinkommen den Tagesschaugang machen?
Danke.
Arbeiten Sie? Okay.
Nochmal vielleicht schon. Jetzt bin ich wieder raus. Tut mir leid. Auch die Umweltstiftung WWF gibt zu bedenken, dass die schlechte Vernetzung von geeigneten Lebensräumen weiterhin ein Problem bleibe. Luchse brauchen zusammenhängende grosse Lebensräume mit viel Wald, Rückzugsorten und ausreichend Beutetieren wie Rehen zum Leben und auf ihre Jungen aufzuziehen. Sie stehen nach wie vor und zum Glück auf der roten Liste der vom Aussterben bedrohten Arten. Super, dankeschön. Da hat man gar nicht gemerkt, dass sie irgendwelche Vorbehalte gegen Luchse haben. Das ist doch gut, das freut mich. So, was mit den Drecksbüchern jetzt? Also die Scheissdrecksbüchern sind mehr unterwegs.
Okay.
Und ja, wie gesagt, ich will nicht sagen, ich bin da allein dafür verantwortlich, aber ich habe finanziell mit dazu beigetragen, dass das funktioniert. Wir werden zurückgespult in die andere Storyline. So, und was auch schwierig ist, ist Mathematik. Und wir haben letzte Woche darüber gesprochen, dass wir so unbedingt gerne, gerne mal eines der Millennium-Probleme lösen würden. Vielen Dank an die vielen Zuschriften von Mathematikern, die uns angeboten haben, uns zu helfen. Nur mal so kurz, uns haben Mathematik Doktoren angeboten mitzumachen, also jetzt an die ganzen Leute, die nur Mathematik studieren, danke nein, danke wir brauchen euch nicht. Aber auch an alle Mathematik-Professoren, wir brauchen noch mehr Leute, wir brauchen noch bessere Leute.
Wir brauchen bessere Leute.
Ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass die Mathematik-Szene so ein bisschen eingeschlafen ist und auf uns gewartet hat. Weil was das für ein Dammbruch war, der Mathematikwelt, die auf uns zugerollt kam, die auf uns zumgerollt kam, als würden die nur endlich auf eine Erlöserfigur warten, die endlich deren Scheissprobleme lösen können, die dann weiterkommen Aber wie gesagt, das ist jetzt natürlich schwer für euch zu erklären, was ein Millenniumproblem ist. Um es kurz zu machen, es gibt Cash, Cash, Cash, eine Million Dollar, falls man es schafft, es rät zu lösen. Moneten, Moneten, Ibiza, Ibiza. Knete, Kröten, alles regnen, prasseln auf uns herab. Das Problem ist, du wolltest ja einen Podcast starten, der erst endet, wenn wir das Problem gelöst haben. Ich habe schnippisch gesagt, der Podcast müsste enden, wenn wir das Problem verstanden haben. Weil viele dieser Probleme sind extrem schwer zu verstehen und für Laien durchaus ungeeignet. Aber mich hat eine Nachricht erreicht, und zwar von Jörg. Jörg ist Mathematiklehrer und der hat ein Problem gefunden, das wir vielleicht sogar lösen könnten. Lieber Florentin, lieber Stefan, ihr redet mal wieder über das Lösen mathematischer Probleme, aber ihr kommt nicht so recht in die Pötte, deswegen von mir heute ein wenig Starthilfe. Fangt an mit der Goldbachschen Vermutung, das ist eine Vermutung von Christian Goldbach, für die auch schon mal eine Million Dollar als Preisgeld ausgelobt wurden, und die ist recht einfach zu verstehen, jede gerade Zahl grösser als zwei ist die Summe zweier Primzahlen. Also es geht um Primzahlen, was waren das noch mal für Zahlen, das waren diese Zahlen zwei, drei, fünf, sieben, elf, dreizehn, also diese Zahlen ohne echte Teiler. Gerade Zahlen grösser als zwei sind vier, sechs, acht, zehn, zwölf usw. Und jede dieser geraden Zahlen soll man laut dieser Vermutung als Summe zweier Primzahlen schreiben können. Wir können zum Beispiel mit der vier anfangen, vier ist zwei plus zwei, das sind zwei Primzahlen, sechs ist drei plus drei, auch zwei Primzahlen. Acht ist drei plus fünf, auch zwei Primzahlen.
Es scheint zu funktionieren, aber noch niemand hat bewiesen, dass es wirklich bei allen geraden Zahlen funktioniert.
Und da kommt ihr bei dem Spiel. Legt jetzt los, holt euch die Millionen, liebe Grüße vom Bodensee.
Och Gott, Leute vom Bodensee müssen immer erwähnen, dass ich vom Bodensee komme.
Vielen, vielen Dank an Jörg, aber wir wissen, was Primzahlen sind. Er redet genau so mit mir wie mein Steuerberater. Immer, das bist du. Und dann meint er so ein Strichmännchen. Genau, das ist der Staat. Ja, ich habe so eine dumme Frage gestellt, okay, aber es ist doch kein Grund, mit mir wie so einem Baby zu reden. Das sind Primzahlen, das sind diese Zahlen, die noch ein bisschen Angst, die kann man nämlich nicht teilen. Eins, drei, ja, wir sind nicht bescheuert. Jörg, also einerseits finde ich gut, dass du uns die Goldbachsche Vermutung nahelegst, aber denkst, wir wissen nicht, was Primzahlen sind, wir wissen, was Primzahlen sind, Primzahlen sind nämlich die Zahlen, die sind nur durch eins teilbar und durch sich selbst teilbar. Die du umdrehen kannst und die dann immer noch so aussehen wie eine andere Zahl. Also sechs, neun, null, acht, das sind Primzahlen. Drei ist eine halbe Primzahl. Drei ist eine HP. Drei ist eine E. Ist eine E quasi und wenn du alle Primzahlen addierst, dann kriegst du die Primqueen, das ist die Summe. Ein Fünftel von Jeff Bezos Umsatz. Und wenn du davon drei hast, dann kriegst du einen Multiplikator, dann ist alles mal zwei, und wenn du vier hast, hast du gewonnen. So, also es ist ganz simpel. Uns musst du nicht erklären, was Primzahlen sind, Jörg. Primzahlen sind natürlich nur durch die Zahl und durch die Zahl eins, das weiß ich selbst. Es gibt eine Menge Primzahlen, das weiß ich auch. Ich würde sagen, es gibt unendlich viele Primzahlen. Ja, und es ist ein schwieriges Problem. Es ist aber eine Vermutung. Ich finde es gut, dass in der Mathematik mit Vermutungen gearbeitet wird. Da haut mal einer was raus und sagt, beweisen kann das jemand anders, aber ich vermute das einfach mal. Kriegt der nicht eine Million? genau, also... Weil die Vermutung ist doch gut.
Das ist eine gute Vermutung. Ich finde, der, der behauptet hat, dass immer
zwei
Primzahlen addiert, eine gerade Zahl
ergeben und die gerade Zahl halt dadurch entstehen kann,
finde ich, ist einfach, der hat es verdient,
eine Million zu bekommen. Der hat eine Vermutung
aufgestellt, die wirkt doch plausibel.
Wir können ihm was abgeben.
Wollen wir an Goldberg vielleicht was abgeben, zu sagen, hier hast du einen Fuffi oder so, so ein Zwei-Zwanziger, von jedem ein Zwanziger. Wir geben Jeff Goldblum was ab. Ich würde sagen, das machen wir. Von allen Einnahmen, die wir durch unsere Mathematikleistungen bekommen, geben wir 10% umgehend an Jeff Goldblum ab, damit der, 10% Jeff Goldblum, 10% Jeff Bezos und 10% Mr. Goldblum, der die Vermutungen aufgestellt hat. Ja, Vermutungen sollen belohnt werden. Das war das Ende der Moderation? Ja, okay, gut. Ja, bin ich auch der Meinung. Also, liebe Professoren und meinetwegen Doktoren, darauf können wir uns noch herablassen, meldet euch bei uns und dann würden wir gerne mit euch gemeinsam, ich finde es geil, wenn wir so ein krasses Experten-Team hätten. Ja, wir brauchen Ghostwriter, die das für uns lösen und wir am Ende unseren Namen draufschreiben und dann sagen, danke für den Cash, für die Kneten, Taster, benehmen's, ohne dass die anderen was bekommen. Das ist meine Idee, so stelle ich mir das vor.
Wir können mal, was ich immer schon mal ausprobieren wollte, ich weiß nicht, wie man das nennt, aber es gibt dieses Phänomen, dieses Verhandlungsphänomen, womit man tolle Leute für seine Sache gewinnen kann. Wir sagen nämlich Professor A, dass wir diesen krassen Professor vom Bodensee B bekommen konnten und krassen Professor von dem Chiemsee C. Und sie sagt, okay, dann mache ich mit. Und den anderen behaupten wir, dass die anderen beiden krassen mitmachen jeweils. Also wir lügen alle an. Und das überzeugende Argument ist ja so eine Self-Fulfilling Prophecy, weil alle mitmachen, weil die jeweils anderen zugesagt haben. Aha, okay. Das ist das alte Beispiel, ich weiß nicht genau, wie es mal ging, aber du kannst ja, wenn du angenommen machst, machst du einen Film. Was trägst du eigentlich bei? Was trägst du bei? Naja, wenn du willst, du hast den Namen nicht, du hast das Beispiel nicht. Doch, dein Beitrag eigentlich? Ich habe die Summe wieder
zusammensetzt. Ich glaube, ich habe die Essenz
noch herauspressen können,
aus diesem Lappen, den ich da noch hatte
im Kopf. Weißt du, das hat noch geklappt,
ehrlich gesagt. Es kam noch genug raus.
Mit viel Kraft, mit viel Energie, mit roten
Knöcheln hast du es geschafft, noch was rauszukommen.
Mit rotem Gesicht und roten Knöcheln habe ich noch
genug Essenz rausgepresst.
Ja. Ich glaube,
Bill Gates. Ich verstehe schon, du lügst
Leute an und sagst, wir haben irgendwelche krassen Leute
Vielen Dank. rotem Gesicht und roten Knöcheln habe ich noch genug Essenz rausgepresst. Ja. Ich glaube, Bill Gates ... Ich weiß nicht, du lügst Leute an und sagst, wir haben irgendwelche krassen Leute zugesagt. Ja, und für deine Veranstaltung Bill Gates, das ist glaube ich das Bill Gates Beispiel, hinzuzugewinnen, sagst du ihm, ja, pass auf, es kommt auch noch der Nobelpreisträger und Jeff Bezos. Und Jeff Bezos sagst, es kommt Bill Gates und der Nobelpreisträger. Und du sagst. Es kommt Jeff Bezos und Bill Gates. Und dann sagen alle natürlich zu, weil die Umgebung krass ist. Aber das alle angelogen. Und dadurch ist so die Wahl gesagt. Und das machen wir jetzt, weil wir behaupten, wir lösen das Millennium-Problem und wir haben schon ein Boot und dann zählen wir jeweils drei Leuten, zwei verschiedene andere krasse Leute auf und so gewinnen wir so ein Masterteam. Dann holen wir uns ganz viel zu essen, stellen so einen Lunchtisch auf. Ja, so Snacks. Ganz viel Snacks. Ganz steriler Raum. Ganz steril, weil wir wissen nicht genau, ob nicht ein unsteriler Raum nicht das Ergebnis verfälscht. Also, ganz steriler, weisser Raum ohne Fenster. Ja, ganz viel Papier. Nur in der Ecke ist so ein Ventilator.
Und dann halt aber so Mikrofone drin.
Und wir sitzen im Nebenraum und hören mit, was die sagen.
Und falls einer sagt, Heureka, dann geht das Licht an bei uns.
Und dann hören wir mit, schreiben das ganz schnell auf,
machen die Schotten dicht.
Die Mathematiker sind eingesperrt.
Schotten dicht, unsere Schotten auf. Und wir rasen durch. Nicht unsere Schotten zu, bitte. Nein. Unsere Schotten dicht. Die Mathematiker sind eingesperrt. Schotten dicht, unsere Schotten auf und wir rasen los. Nicht unsere Schotten zu, bitte. Nein. Unsere Schotten auf. Weit auf und wir rennen los. Genau. Gas strömt wohin eigentlich? Aus der Tür, so dass wir einen coolen Auftritt haben. In die Garage. Ich mache Motorrad-Führerschein bis dahin und du hängst dich dann so hinten so fest. Genau, du sitzt auf dem Motorrad, fährst schon los, ich renne noch hinterher mit dem Zettel in der Hand, schwenke ihn über meinen Kopf, springe auf dich drauf. Wir wissen noch nicht, dass es ein Zettel ist, den wir am Ende haben als Lösung. Es kann auch, ich sag nur, es ist ja noch eine Box. Es kann eine Box sein. Was Dreidimensionales. Vielleicht ist es ein Säckel, vielleicht ist es ein Säcklein, vielleicht ist es ein Beutel, vielleicht ist es eine Tüte. Wir wissen es nicht hundertprozentig. Du hast jedenfalls, du schwenkst etwas in deiner Hand, ich bremse ein bisschen, du springst auf und dann und dann gehst du los. Wheelie, Swooperoo, Swooperoo, wir fahren los. Währenddessen Schnitt zu den Mathematikern. Hallo, wir haben die Lösung. Ah, da muss irgendwas falsch sein mit der Tür. Irgendwas läuft hier falsch. Ich hab mein Geodreieck dabei. Was du gerade verwechselst, ist, während die mit Zirkel und Geodreieck an der Tür rumfuchteln, um die aufzubekommen, dass es Mathematiker sind, die haben schon lange durchschaut. Hebel gesetzt? Nein, die haben schon lange durchschaut. Wie? Im Flashback erfahren wir dann später, dass sie zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon geflohen sind. Ach, Twist! Plot Twist. Die haben uns nämlich gedouble-crossed. Das war nämlich nur ... Warum lassen wir das zu? Das waren so Luke Skywalker Force Visions. Ja, warum wir das zulassen? Weil das Mathematiker sind, die sind schlauer als wir, deswegen mussten wir die ja zuziehen. Sie hätten auch selber das Problem lösen können. Ich weiß, ich bin genauso erstaunt vom Plot Twist wie du. So, aber ... Ich dachte, wir hätten auf alles geachtet. Die kommen in ihrem Mathe-Mobil, nämlich überholen uns dann auf der Autobahn plötzlich, ungemerkt. Ah ja, die in ihrem Mathe-Mobil mit so Dreiecken als Räder, was sich rausstellen viel schneller ist. Was wussten wir bis dahin nicht. Und die sind super schnell und wir mit unseren ollen Kreisrädern viel zu langsam. Und die überholen uns,
ziehen uns vorbeischwenken, auch was über dem Kopf.
Du hast so eine Müllklemme,
so eine Müllgreife. Nerf Gun. Ach so. Oder das.
Versuchst, den Zettel wegzunehmen,
weil damit hast du schon ein bisschen gerechnet.
Plötzlich, du machst den Triple Cross,
hast von Anfang an damit gerechnet,
dass sie uns Double Crossen.
Ich bin erstaunt. Du bist generell, du bist amazed von Minute eins. Close up auf mich. Augen aufgerissen, du cool lässig, hast vielleicht so ein Visierrunden bei deiner Vespa oder so. Ja. So ein Sonnenbrillenvisier. Clemstar mit dem, da gibt es so eine Action-Vesier. Wie, okay, no, keine schlechte Idee. Ä im Kölner Stadtverkehr are actions 10 Minuten lang. Ich bin in Köln? Natürlich, wo denn sonst? Ja, ich dachte, Stockholm, weiß ich nicht. Okay, von mir aus. Stockholmer Stadtverkehr, 10 Minuten hin und her, die fahren voraus mit ihrem Mathe-Mobil, wir hinterher mit dem Müllgreifer.
Nach einer zehnminütigen Verfolgungsjahr frage ich dich,
wie bereits gefragt,
wohin fahren wir?
Du machst das immer, immer wenn du mich fragst,
sagst du mich, ja und jetzt noch mal,
du hast aber nie davor
die Frage gestellt, du lässt mich
immer wie ein Vollidiot aus.
Weil wir das rausgeschnitten haben, weil ich das schlecht gespielt habe.
Aber ich hätte dich schon ein paar Mal gefragt. Das machst du immer, du kommst immer zu mir und sagst, so jetzt zum dritten Mal, wo müssen wir hin? Und das war auch das erste Mal, dass wir erst mal hallo, ja, erst mal hi, komm erst mal rein, sprich nicht durchs Fenster zu mir, also wo kommst du denn her? Jetzt nochmal, wo fahren wir denn überhaupt hin? So, und dann sage ich zum Nobelpreis Haus. Haben die so ein Komiteehaus? Vereinshaus? Nee, zu einem Briefkasten. Hä? Oder? Woran ist der Brief adressiert? Und die Verfolgungsdrechte ist zu einem Briefkasten? Wie lame ist das denn? Da sind wir schon an drei vorbeigekommen. Du weißt, wie wenig Briefkästen es in Stockholm gibt? Ja, die Leute waren noch nie in Stockholm, die checken das nicht. Und Verwagungsjagd, aber natürlich auch übers Wasser. Die springen dann auf so ein Motorboot und wir auf einem Jetski hinterher, ich sitze wieder hinter dir. Das ist hier aber durch, das ist schon immer der unbeholfene bis, wo man die ganze Zeit denkt als Zuschauer, lass den. Warum ist der dabei? Der soll einfach, warum du brauchst den nicht. Und du sagst, okay, irgendwann sage ich, stimmt, weil ich mache so eine Charakterentwicklung durch von dem Trottel, der nichts versteht, der immer nur überrascht ist, zu jetzt nehme ich das Ruder in die Hand, sag, fahr mich nur nah genug dran, ich habe eine Idee. Oh Gott, okay. Und du sagst, okay. Okay, Sam. Und dann gibst du nochmal richtig Gas, fährst nah genug an das Mathemobil der Mathematiker ran und dann werfe ich dich rüber. Dann habe ich doch nochmal Zweifel. Dann nehme ich meinen, dann hole ich aus meiner Tasche meinen Grimmepreis raus. Alle! Damit haben wir nicht gerechnet.
Das hatten wir nicht im Zettel.
Und ich Senf!
Werfe den Grimmepreis,
treffe auf den Kopf, reiße das Lenkrad rum,
fährt in die Brücke, kaputt, tot.
Wir fahren in den Sonnenuntergang.
Alle tot.
Ja, alle tot.
Wir fahren in den Sonnenuntergang,
haben die eine Million und dann einfach so eine
Shopping-Spree. Dann will ich so einen richtig
gnadenlos harten Cut.
Und dann geht nämlich der Film los. Das ist der
Anfang des Films ist, wir haben das geschafft.
Eine Million Dollar.
Baby, you're a rich man.
Zwei Songs
laufen gleichzeitig, weil wir uns
für Mädels-Fans und für Stones-Fans.
Das war alle was dabei. Naja, es ist eine sehr kleine Gruppeans und für Stones-Fans, das war alle was dabei.
Naja, es ist eine sehr kleine Gruppe, mit einer grossen Nützmenge ist was dabei, aber wir beide konnten uns nicht entscheiden, das wurde sehr immanent. Das war für den Verleih wichtig, dass die Zielgruppe halt gross ist von dem Film, da ist sowohl Beatles als auch Stones drin, was wollen sie mehr? Ja, so, durch diesen Höllenlärm ziehen wir durch Mailand und kaufen ein Shopping, Shopping, Shopping, dann gibt es so Szenen wie, du gehst in die umkleine Kabine, Jumpcut, du kommst raus, exotisches.
Und du siehst jetzt so Champagnerglas in der Hand und bist ganz einfach tanzen. Genau, und ich sag so, no way, girl, und dann gehst du wieder in die Kabine, jump cut, kommst wieder raus und hast so einen coolen Anzug an und du sagst, that's more like it, und dann, that's how you do it, girl, ja, so, das zu sagen. Ich würde den gesamten Film auf der verzweifelten Suche nach einem Catch-Race. Ich probiere Dinge aus, aber die bleiben nicht hängen, so ein bisschen, das ist das Problem. Ja, das ist der Film. Das ist der Film. Guck mal, wir haben heute zwei Filme geschrieben. Es ist so leicht, die Leute sagen immer, wie schwer, das ist eine Serie zu schreiben. Ich kann das ja nicht. Ich habe eine Serie geschrieben, ich will auch einen Grimme-Preis. Ich habe auch keinen Grimme-Preis. Ich habe zwei Staffeln geschrieben und kriege keinen Grimme-Preis. Und du machst eine Stunde Senf und kriegst einen Grimme-Preis. Die Antwort ist Senf, nie so häufig. Es ist auch nicht so schwer, sowas zu schreiben. Es ist leicht. Es ist leicht. Es ist auf eine Art, es ist leicht. Man muss halt nur das machen, was andere Filme auch machen. Nimm dir irgendeinen schwedischen Film, den keiner kennt und schreib den nach. Mein Gott. Aber das ist mittlerweile, glaube ich, nicht mehr möglich. Das hat früher ja Bill Cosby, Bill Cosby hat ja alles von Jürgen von der Lippe aufgeschrieben. Das wissen viele nicht. Aber Bill Cosby ist eine 1 zu 1 Kopie von Jürgen von der Lippe. Auch Chris Rock ist 1 zu 1 Harpe Kerkeling eigentlich. Ja, 1 zu 1. Wie viele wissen das nicht? Kaffee Korte, das ist von Harpe Kerkeling. Das ist nicht Chris Rock. Es ist im Original von Harpe Kerkeling, ja. Das ist verrückt, aber wenn man das mal weiß, kann man das auch nicht mehr angucken. Amy Schumer, 1 zu 1, Anke Engelke. Ja! Also kannst du wirklich 1 zu 1 die Programme nebeneinander legen. Peinlich, peinlich. Peinlich, peinlich, Louis C.K., alles von Ingo Appelt eigentlich. Es ist 1 zu 1 Ingo Appelt, inklusive der Skandälchen. Ja, aber nur so wird man fake it till you make it.
Das L da drin braucht man nicht.
Doch, das ist Kurt Drain, das ist drin.
Nee, es ist fake it till you make it.
Es ist fake it till you, what was it again, ah ja, make it.
So ist das Sprichwort.
Das ist das Sprichwort.
Aber das ist auch, ja, so ein Nobody is perfect, das ist doch ein Gag, oder?
So, jetzt guck mal, jetzt wendet sich der Wurm, jetzt wendet sich der Tisch.
Da habe ich kurz gelacht.
Nobody is perfect, das ist doch ein Wand-Tattoo.
Das ist ein Tweet.
Gibt es aber auch 100% schon, oder?
Nobody is perfect.
Aber gibt es schon, oder? Just do it. Ja. Nee. Don't think twice. Twice. Ja, sowas. Wie gesagt, guckt mal, was für euch funktioniert, nehmt euch was raus. Wir wissen aber nicht, in welcher Timeline ihr gerade seid. Wir gucken mal ganz kurz, ein ganz kurzer Blick in die andere Timeline. Mach das aus! Aus, mach das aus! Mach das Feuer aus! Legs weg, legs weg, legs weg! Denen wird es auch gut gehen in der anderen Timeline, ehrlich gesagt. Denen wird es auch gut gehen. Gut, ich wünsche dir eine fantastische Woche, dass du mir nicht abhebst, dass du mir mit Florentin bleibst. Nein, aber auch bei dir, dass du mir nicht abstürzt, bitte, bleib noch hängen. Dass ich vor Neid nicht abstürze. Dass du nicht vor Neid platzt, wie man so schön sagt. Hast du noch eine kleine Empfehlung für uns für die Woche, was du so treibst, worauf hast du Lust, worauf freust du dich? Bowlen gehen? Ich habe generell keine Freude mehr am Leben. Doch, ich habe jetzt für mich, ja, nee, das kann ich nicht mehr wieder empfehlen. Ich möchte was anderes empfehlen. Ich will wieder Glee. Ich kann nicht mehr wieder High Street Musical 2 empfehlen als Geheimtipp, den man nicht auf dem Zettel hat. Ähm, nee, heute mag ohne Empfehlung. Gut, es ist eine Premiere in der Podcast-Uvo-Geschichte. Keine Empfehlung, diese Woche müsst ihr mal selber gucken, wo ihr leid. Nee, genau deswegen, weil das ist nämlich wie bei Tieren, die man nicht füttern soll die ganze Zeit, weil die dann vergessen, nämlich selber, sie fressen sie. Genau, das ist was mit dem Luchs passiert. Ist nämlich, wir sind ja an euch interessiert. Wir wollen ja nicht die ganze Zeit immer nur empfehlen, damit ihr vergesst, selber zu entscheiden, was ihr gut findet. Was findet ihr denn gut, Tom und Nina, wie er alle heißt? Clara, hau mal was raus! Was findet ihr denn gut? Paul! Nicht immer nur, was Florentin, der Gremotpreisträger Florentin will, sagt, was er gut findet. Nein, ihr müsst mir selber sagen, was ihr gut findet. Und damit entlassen wir euch in die Woche. Habt eine schöne Woche. Habt eine sehr, sehr schöne Woche. Macht es gut, wir sehen uns nächste Woche, wenn es wieder heisst.
Hi.
Hier ist das Podcast-Wofo.
Bis dahin, heben wir ab.
So was?
Perpetuction.